The last four nights, I have been having night sweats mostly around the head and neck, which is odd.
Is there something I could do for the night sweats, any programs?
So night sweats are a sign of something.
So it's not necessarily what we want to do for.
We want to figure out what you're having these night sweats, what it's caused by.
No, a person can have night sweats.
If they are on, if they have a cancer that is a hormone driven cancer, let's say they have ERPR positive cancer
and we have them on an aromatase inhibitor supplement, or they're on an aromatase inhibitor medication.
That can certainly give you night sweats because you're basically putting yourself into an estrogen deprivation
and that's the goal of those things.
And you are basically getting these hot flash type things.
If you don't have that type of cancer and we don't have you on that type of product,
then there's other reasons why a person gets night sweats.
A person with lymphoma and get night sweats because lymphoma can affect your hormone balance
and you can get night sweats from the lymphoma.
So we should really have a discussion with the person who wrote this.
If you want to call and talk and we should make an appointment, there aren't any specific right programs for night sweats.
You deal with it.
You use the right treatment or nutritional treatment or medication or whatever based upon the cause of it.
So we'd be looking at really those two things.
Night sweats are either cause from a cancer like a lymphoma or from a hormone disruption
like somebody going through benapause or somebody going through a forced reduction in estrogen
by taking some sort of aromatase inhibitor product.